we are looking at live shots here from
NTV a Turkish broadcaster showing you
clearly big crowds gathering around a
square the president called for big
crowds also to go to the airport we have
seen footage of roads being blocked off
bridges being blocked off and we've seen
pictures of police being detained by
armed forces our colleague Isabel Finkel
has been joining us throughout the past
couple of hours she is with Bloomberg
News joining us now on the phone from
Istanbul Isabel what's the latest she
ran home when when news of this coup
came out over the wives but now people
do seem to be taking to the streets in
response to as you say of course one
president adds on for people to come out
and show show their opposition to it so
there are clashes I believe by people
you know who heated the school and
others who are trying to keep the peace
and in some way but it's a very
complicated situation that's developing
as we speak you are as well you are in
Istanbul and we've heard reports of
gunfire helicopters military jets being
scrambled over both Istanbul and Ankara
are you hearing anything about the rest
of Turkey I mean that is does make up
about a fifth of the population there 14
million people in Istanbul about 5
million in Ankara but is this happening
only in those two cities or do you hear
that it's happening all over the country
so far it seems to be centered around
uncle which as you know is the capital
and Istanbul Turkey's bigger city also
the commercial capital where where all
the banks and you know financial
institutions are so it does seem to be
focused in those two places colleagues
around you know in uncle saying that
they've actually had sort of you know
bombs explosions on the street out there
so it seems that the violence that
you're you're seeing it is much more
concentrated in Ankara where our
government is based and where the chief
of staff building is but
Istanbul as well certainly there's a lot
of confusion and and earlier you know
that they shut the bridges that go
across the Bosphorus soldiers closed
those bridges to traffic so we're also
feeling it but not as strongly as Uncle
Jesse is about we are seeing pictures on
TV of people taking to the streets in
Turkey this is what President Erdogan
urged them to do does he believe that a
number of people will heed his call take
to the streets and in a sense engage in
a peaceful protest and trying to
convince the military that what they're
doing is wrong I think that certainly
his his hope and his intention I can
hear people's repeated his his cool
right now I can I can hear chance coming
from Istanbul central Taksim Square were
only three years ago there were
anti-government protests a very
different kind of protest was taking
place if you remember in a protest
broadcast about the construction project
in Istanbul Central Park and people took
over the square there for days whether
this is going to be a flash in the pan
or the restored by morning or otherwise
from Main Street scene Isabel are you
getting any reports some that we are
hearing that martial law has been
declared in Turkey at least until
further notice that's indeed what we're
hearing though there are a lot of very
contradictory messages at the moment the
traction within the army that staging
this coup attempt see seems to have
seized TRT the state broadcaster and
they're declaring Martial Law
officials within the government on the
other hand are saying no that's not the
case if whatever this coup attempt is
will fight it will be successful in
fighting it and we have the backing of
the people so there are contradictory
messages from each faction going on at
the moment and it's little bit hard to
get clarity yeah I wonder if the
contradictory messages from president
air Diwan seem a little tongue-in-cheek
I mean president air diwan's a strongman
ruler if he's calling for a peaceful and
to this coup you have two one
how house how honest he's being because
from the academics that we've been
speaking to and the experts that have
been on the last hour it seems that this
is a leader who's willing to wage war in
order to stay in power well certainly
he's had a very tenacious grip on power
in Turkey over the last few years he was
mayor of Istanbul in the 90s then
subsequently was prime minister for many
many years more than a decade in fact
and then was popularly elected president
in 2014 he was Turkey's first popular
elected president previously had been a
parliamentary appointment and so having
won that vote he can certainly say he
has the support of the people 52% of the
people but there's obviously a huge
faction that as well as one that loyal
to him a huge faction that that doesn't
like him doesn't like what he's doing
doesn't like his party and previously
these people were represented by the
army and he spent a lot of time trying
to curtail the Army's influence in
Turkish public life people thought he'd
been very successful in that but it
seems that there are still some factions
in the army that have the power and the
intention to do this Bloomberg's Isabel
Finkel joining us on the phone from
Istanbul Turkey Isabel thank you very
much